AC la Haus des taux d'intérêt la France
peut-elle se retrouver en faillite quels
sont les risques d'une crise monétaire
est-ce que on pourrait arriver à celle
subie par la Grèce il y a 15 ans comment
financer ça c'est très important les
transformations indispensables de notre
société dans de telles conditions avant
d'en débattre Cécile sixsou tente
d'escalader le mur de la dette
française c'est un record une explosion
la dette publique en France a dépassé la
barre symbolique des 3000 milliards
d'euros elle représente aujourd'hui plus
de 110 % du PIB ce qui place la France
dans le top 3 des pays les plus endettés
en Europe derrière la Grèce et l'Italie
pour redresser la barre le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire s'est dit près
début janvier à prendre des décision
difficilees je rappelle que nous devons
trouver au minimum au minimum 12
milliards d'euros d'économie pour
2025 appelons donc un chat un chat en
matière de finan publi le plus dur est
devant nous le pire reste à venir pas
vraiment pour le sénateur communiste éc
beet lui voit dans cette annonce une
stratégie du gouvernement pour mieux
faire accepter ses réformes par les
Français il y a le discours anxiogène
celui qu'on entend attention la dette la
dette s entendu on va mourir et puis un
discours culpabilisateur vous endettez
vos enfants vos petits enfants c'est
scandaleux ce que vous faites c'est ça
que les gens entendent donc les gens
culpabilisés et inquiets peut-être
qu'ils sonont plus plus aptes à accepter
les réformes qu'on veut leur imposer
pour la sénatrice Christine Lavarde le
boom de la dette doit être stoppé car
elle coûte cher et représente une trop
grosse partie des dépenses de l'État et
c'est vrai que dans les quelques années
qui sont derrière nous s sen deté était
quasiment gratuit hein sauf que
maintenant avec la remontée très rapide
des taux d'intérêts le poids de la dette
coûte beaucoup plus cher et d'ailleurs
on le voit puisque aujourd'hui euh le
budget que l'État doit consacrer
uniquement au paiement des intérêts même
pas au remboursement du capital he
vraiment le paiement des intérêts excède
c'est c'est il reste plus que le budget
de l'éducation national qui est
supérieure l'Europe moins regardante sur
les règles budgétaires depuis la
pandémie a repris son rôle de gendarme
depuis le 1emer janvier dernier si la
France ne fait rien elle pourrait donc
se faire épingler par
Bruxelles la France peut-elle se
retrouver en failit on en débat avec
Christine kerelland bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste économique et
écrivain auteur de milliardair plus fort
que les États c'est aux éditions de
l'Observatoire Didier rambau bonsoir
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
renaissance de liser et vice-président
de la commission des finances gésabelle
coup souberan bonsoir et bienvenue
maîtresse de conférence d'économie à
l'université parisen Panthéon Sorbonne
conser scientifique à l'Institut weblen
et auteur de ce livre le pouvoir de la
monnaie aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent Émilie zapski l'itorialiste
politique est resté à mes côtés pourquoi
ce titre parce que je fais référence
évidemment à cette phrase de Françis
fris Fillon je suis à la tête d'un État
en faillite il était alors Premier
ministre elle date de novembre 2011
Christine cardellan a pas vraiment le
sentiment que ça s'est arrangé depuis
est-ce que notre niveau de dette est
historiquement haut est-ce qu'on a déjà
vu ça alors sauf à à revenir après 1945
après la la 2ème guerre mondiale puisque
là on s'était beaucoup endetté ou à
revenir à l'époque de Louis XV ou de
Colbert Suly et cetera mais sinon si on
regarde depuis la près-gerre euh
effectivement c'est un niveau historique
on n jamais aussi bien en volume enfin
on est à à 3088 milliards
euh de d'euros ce qui est quand même
spectaculaire et on est à
111,7 % du PIB et ça aussi c'est
historique donc donc oui qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à la question la France
enfin est-ce que finalement Emmanuel
Macron ou Gabriel Atal sont à la tête
d'un État en faillite bon on est en
faillite depuis je crois 1974 qui est la
dernière année où le budget a été
positif
le budget de l'État depuis on a toujours
été soit à peu près l'équilibre soit en
négatif autour de 3 % les dernières
années de de du mandat François Hollande
et puis depuis depuis
2019 largement au-dessus de 3 % de
déficit donc oui on est en faillite mais
on est peut-être tout big tout fa mais
ça c'est pas un trop gros pour mourir
évidemment détailler ça va être le thème
principal de de notre débat et on
reparlera des agences de notation parce
que c'est un des intéressant de dire
votre avis la question principale de
notre débat volontairement elle est un
peu piquante la France la France en
faillite non je trouve que le terme est
peut-être encore excessif si je peux me
permettre de reprendre on n'est pas en
faillite depuis 1974 on a effectivement
un budget de l'État qui est en déficite
depuis 1974 toute la question c'est de
savoir dans quelle mesure ce déficit est
acceptable pour nos finan puis ce
sentiment de fatalité quoi enfin ça peut
pas être une fatalité quo ah non c'est
clair que je crois que d'ailleurs je me
réjouis de ce débat parce que faut
reconnaître que dans l'opinion
publique et même au niveau de la classe
politique on n'est pas beaucoup
intéressé par ce thème on le fuit on
laisse on laisse filer hein voilà ce qui
compte c'est effectivement c'est de
c'est de donner satisfaction à tous les
corporatismes possibles toutes les
revendications tous les tous les sujets
qu'on peut qu'on peut aborder et donc on
le fuit ce débat mais effectivement je
crois que là maintenant par contre je
suis d'accord on est au pied du mur et
il est temps de de rectifier la le mur
de la dette regardez l'évolution de la
dette publique française depuis l'an
2000 on est était à
870 milliards à l'époque et donc
3088 milliards aujourd'hui Jésabel coupé
souéran c'est c'est un quand on quand on
regarde cette ce graphique est-ce que
c'est un toboggan infernal comment vous
vous qualifiez cette situation de la
dette française bah de crise en crise
effectivement la la dette publique a
augmenté c'està-dire que là ce que ce
que nous voyons à travers cette
évolution c'est ce qui s'est passé après
la crise financière de 200728 ouis qui s
pass AC la pandémie et la nécessité
effectivement et bien de mener si vous
voulez une une politique de une
politique budgétaire assez assez intense
beaucoup plus d'ailleurs pendant la
pandémie que pendant la que pendant la
crise financière est-ce que c'est une
maladie française mais ce qui est
intéressant finalement dans la façon
dont vous posez la question sont les
éléments de langage là que vous mettez
en avant vous vous demandez si on est
dans un état en
faillite fond vous voyez ces éléments de
langage traduisent un peu l'ordre auquel
la dette nous soumet c'est-à-dire que
lorsque les États se financent en
empruntant sur les marchés financiers
lorsque le financement passe par la
dette et bien la dette ensuite constitue
un moyen de pression pour pouvoir
orchestrer des politiques de réduction
de la dépense alors je suis pas en train
de dire non plus si vous voulez qu'il
faut fermer les yeux euh sur cette sur
cette ascension je pense d'ailleurs que
lorsque la dette est contractée sur des
marchés financiers effectivement euh on
a une contrainte de soutenabilité de
cette dette sinon à un moment donné et
bien les investisseurs peuvent paniquer
euh avoir un comportement de défiance et
on peut tout à fait être exposé on l'a
déjà vécu euh à une crise de de la dette
souveraine la zone euro a affronté ça
donc donc il s'agit pas de dire que il
faut fermer les yeux sur cette ascension
continue de la dette mais il faut quand
même aussi s'interroger sur la pression
que ça installe et moi ce qui m'inquiète
le plus dans cette histoire ce sont les
dépenses qu'il nous faudrait réaliser
les dépenses publiques qu'il nous
faudrait réaliser les dépenses
d'investissement pour transformer nos
économies al ça on y reviendra un peu
plus tard c'est pour je tiens en général
dans mes débats je tiens mes promesses
donc ce thème-là je l'ai prévu et
évidemment il est il est très important
vous vouz intervenir moi je me poserai
pas la question dans ce sens est-ce que
l'État est en faillite mais est-ce que
notre modèle social économique qu'on
choisit en fonction du contexte et de la
conjoncture est-ce qu'il est tenable
est-ce qu'il est soutenable est-ce qu'il
est rentable comme n'importe quelle
entreprise se pose la question de son
modèle économique et de voir s'il est
tenable je prends un exemple simplement
avant la crise covid les taux d'intérêt
étaient plutôt à la baisse et si je je
je fais ça sous votre contrôle si je
comprends bien on empruntait de l'argent
un peu pas cher à tel point que certains
organismes comme France stratégie
disaient allons-y allons-y allons-y
prenons de l'avance sur la transition
énergétique parce que pour l'instant
l'argent coûte pas très cher et on n'
pas su le faire alors qu'on a emprunté
énormément pour financer le covid donc
est-ce que nos modèles sont pas ajustés
pour justement jouer sur ça est-ce que
nos modèles économiques et sociaux
français he qui qui sont très qui qui
dépensent beaucoup est-ce que c'est
tenable est-ce qu'il faut faire des
choix au-delà de la pression
conjoncturelle c'est peut-être ça qu'il
faudrait questionner parce qu'on a fait
des choix et on et c'est la philosophie
française mais est-ce qu'on peut les
assumer tout le temps ou est-ce que est
que de manière maline on pourrait les
financer de temps en temps comme un bon
ou une bonne pa de mère de famille si le
taux d'intérêt baisse sauf que
évidemment parce que moi moi je
effectivement je réagis un peu comm je
regarde mon budget de dis c'est horrible
évidemment fait pas la même chose avec
un état on va rappeler de quelques bases
économique quand même non on fait pas la
même chose avec un état parce que c'est
la France mais certains États peuvent
pas du tout être en déficite parce
qu'ils ont du mal à se financer sur les
marchés financiers des des États
africains ouou même la Grèce enc
aujourd'hui heureusement qu'elle a
l'Europe derrière elle mais c'est plus
compliqué de se financer alors quand on
est la France il y a un beau marché ce
qu'on appelle marché de la dette qui est
abondant et puis on est un État a priori
solide donc les gens ont confiance et et
achètent nos nos nos obligations du
Trésor mais c'est pas forcément le cas
de tout le monde et ça va pas forcément
durer éternellement alors et ça suppose
de rembourser tous les mois c'est ce
qu'on appelle la la charge de la dette
Bruno Lemire voudrait bien stopper
l'hémorragie AG surtout avec ces taux
d'intérêt qui ont flambé depuis 2 ans et
cette charge de la dette écoutez-le elle
lui fait mal au cœur moi je vais vous
dire ça me fait mal au cœur d'avoir une
charge de la dette qui soit aussi élevée
car c'est de l'argent jeté par les
fenêtres ça suffit et je le dis à tous
ceux qui n disent mais dépenseer plus
pas de problème avec la dette
endettez-vous d'avantage mais quand on a
des taux d'intérêt à 4 % c'est
totalement irresponsable de plaider pour
un allordissement de la dette et de la
charge de la dette cet argent-l moi je
veux l'employer pour la décarbonation je
l'employer pour ma prime Reno jeis
l'employé pour la rénovation des
bâtiments publics je l'employé pour le
financement des véhicules électriques et
l'industrie verte en France c'est ça
l'argent bien employé Bruno maire qui
promet 12 milliards d'euros d'économie
pour 2025 Didier rambon où peut-il les
trouver c'estàdire que il y a il y a le
déclaratif et puis ensuite il a ce qu'on
va réussir à faire d'abord faut regarder
un petit peu ce qui a été fait ces
dernières années hein je crois qu'il y a
quand même des réformes structurelles
qui ont été engagées la réforme des
retraites voilà on l'a peut-être mal
expliqué l'an dernier quand on a voté
cette cette réforme parce que avant tout
rappelons quand même que les les
dépenses sociales représentent à peu
près 50 % de nos dépenses publiques et
les paiements des retraites c'est à peu
près 50 % des dépenses sociales donc
c'est déjà commençons par maîtriser ses
retraites l'assurant chômage donc
deuxième aussi grande réforme
structurelle et puis derrière et ben oui
oui oui effectivementir le courage
d'engager ce qu'on appelle un peu la
revue des dépenses publiques peut-être
s'interroger aussi savoir si est-ce
qu'on dépense bien hein parce que je
constate dans dans grand pi mcomissi qui
qui euh président de la Cour des comptes
qui sait mettre la pression euh sur les
gouvernements et sur le le locataire de
de Bery dit il faut mieux répartir les
dépenses publiques et un argent public
mieux dépensé c'est le dernier message
qu'il a fait passer à on a des exemples
de politiqu publiqu où en Europe on
dépense on est le pays qui dépense le
plus le logement par exemple et on a une
crise de logement donc quelque part ça
pose problème quoi je veux dire est-ce
que tous nos dispos nos dépenses
fiscales dispositifs fiscaux le Pinel le
PTZ est-ce qu'ils sont bien adaptés euh
on pourrait aussi parler de l'éducation
chaque fois qu'on considère qu' qu'il y
a un problème il faut dépenser plus pour
pourquoi et on a les plus mauvais
classements PISA en tout cas on n pas on
n pas dans les meilleurs on n'est pas
dans les meilleurs donc quelque part ça
doit interper et derrière donc c'est
toute cette réflexion est-ce
qu'effectivement on dépense bien voilà
sans pourant voilà plutôt que de
dépenser plus faut dépenser mieux près
de 4,5 milliards chaque mois c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ça la charge de la
dette un peu moins 4 milliards TR et
quelquesavis le coupé souon il a raison
Bruno Le Maire c'est de l'argent perdu
pour les transformations dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure mais c'est de
c'est de l'argent associé au mode de
financement euh de de l'État euh
aujourd'hui et depuis si vous voulez les
années 70 c'est-à-dire que jusque dans
les années 70 les États avaient la
possibilité de se financer par des
avances de la Banque centrale et puis on
s'est dit que ce type de financement
monétaire était inflationniste et qu'il
fallait en passer par un financement de
de marché tout ça c'est inscrit dans une
dans une politique de libéral isation le
le financement sur le sur le marché
c'est un c'est un emprunt obligataire
qui a un certain prix qu'on appelle le
taux d'intérêt alors c'est vrai qu'on a
passé si vous voulez plusieurs années de
de taux d'intérêt très bas voire négatif
pour certains états ce qui était une
anomalie historique on pe
dire effectivement quand le quand le
prix de l'argent euh emprunté auprès
d'investisseurs privés euh
devient nul voire négatif oui on peut
parler on peut parler de de pathologie
maintenant que les taux remontent la
charge de la dette remonte et si vous me
permettez juste également de revenir sur
les quelques éléments de de langage hein
là encore l'état n'est pas un père de
famille et
l'é non mais c'est très important parce
que si vous voulez ça ça conditionne
véritablement ensuite la la la vision la
vision du monde donc on gère pas on gère
pas un état comme comme on gère
unetet familial et l'é n'est pas une
entreise quand même pardon vous
interrompe Christine cardan le le ce ce
changement de de pied sur le le coût de
l'argent c'est les taux d'intérêt qui
ont quand même flambé en en quoi en un
an ils sont passé gros modo de zéro à à
4 % 4 % bon c'est est-ce que ça ça veut
pas dire quand même que ce ce modèle de
d'endettement n'est plus tenable vous
voyez ce que je veux dire à quel point
ça ça parce que là on vient de on vient
d'écouter le discours de politique
générale du du Premier ministre qui qui
annonce des un certain nombre de M mais
à quel point on peut engager des
réformes transformer un pays avec une
charge de la dette aussi importante ben
c'est vrai que c'est c'est devenu
indispensable c'estàd qu'on peut plus là
je crois qu'en 2020 en 2027 on aura une
charge de la dette plus importante que
les dépenses pour éducation nationale
donc ça devient dramatique on est très
au-delà des dépenses de défense de
sécurité enfin les dépenses régaliennes
voilà et les dépenses donc effectivement
on est obligé de le changer alors tout à
l'heure on faisait allusion au fait que
la on est n'utilise pas assez
efficacement no dépenses publiques je
crois qu'il faut prendre modèle sur des
pays comme la Suède on l'a fait souvent
mais eux aussi ils étaient à 62 % du PIB
leur dépens publiqu était à 62 % du PIB
et ils ont réussi à ramener à 48 % en
remettant à plat toutes les dépenses
publiques alors c'est vrai que c'est
c'est le logement c'est l'éducation et
c'est la santé essentiellement si vous
prenez l'Allemagne en Allemagne vous
êtes aussi bien soigné aussi bien logé
et aussi bien éduqué avec des inférieur
alors pourquoi la France est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on a accumulé ça veut dire
quoi il faut remettre à plat voilà une
dépense qui ser à quelque chose ou pas
et quand ça sert à rien on la supprime
mais c'est presque le modèle à chaque
fois qui est à remettre en cause c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué
ça changer alors vous parliez du mot
dette et du fait c'est super qu'on fasse
un débat là-dessus parce que ça
intéresse pas grand monde Émilie c'est
pas non plus le thème préféré d'uel
Macron alors non pas un mot sur la dette
lors de sa dernière conférence de presse
le grand rendez-vous avec la nation le
terme n'a pas été cé et si en 2018
Emmanuel Macron avait prévenu qu'il n'y
avait pas d'argent magique il a vite
sorti le carnet de chèque crise des
gilets jaunes 17 milliards d'euros en
dépenses ou bien en suppression de
recettes comme l'annulation de la hausse
de la taxe carbone qui était le le sujet
original de la discorde on est passé à
la crise sanitaire 140 milliards d'euros
avec l'activation du quoi qu'il en coûte
même chose ou presque pour la guerre en
Ukraine la crise énergétique la hausse
de l'inflation le tout pour arriver
comme on l'a dit à une dette de plus de
3000 milliards d'euros qui arrive à
quasiment à mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que faire baisser la dette ce serait pas
forcément dans l'esprit du en même temps
d'Emmanuel Macron alors Emmanuel Macron
avait tenté le coup en début de premier
quinquena je vous cite juste l'essai de
la diminution de 5 € sur les APL les
allocations personnalisées de logement
il l'a traîné ensuite comme un boulet
cette essai là il s'était aussi fixé un
objectif de moins 120000 fonctionnaires
qui a tout simplement disparu au moment
gilets jaune il n'en a plus parlé en
fait plus que la réduction des dépenses
Macron mise sur la croissance et sur le
plein emploi pour réduire la dette
malheureusement il se base souvent sur
des projections qui sont très optimistes
par exemple enfin il a fait des grands
plan d'investissement France 2030 France
relance à la suite des crises mais la
croissance bah elle stagne donc ça
produit pas plus et le chômage qui était
en forte réduction commence à
réaugmenter petit à petit alors on a
entendu Bruno Lemer tire régulièrement
la la sonnette d'alarme est-il forcément
entendu en tout cas il y a de nouveau
risque de dérapage ah oui sans action
volontaire difficile de réduire la dette
et puis les premières annonces de de
Gabri à la tal pour calmer les colères
la colère des agriculteurs bah ça
dessine un petit peu le retour du quoi
qu'il en coûte hein on a 50 millions
d'euros par-ci pour le bio l'arrêt de la
hausse sur le gazol non routier ça
ressemble un peu au gilets jaune et
peut-être d'autres mesures puisque on a
dit qu'il y en aurait d'autres le
gouvernement a annoncé ça la perfusion
finalement elle a été dure à retirer
après le covid la tentation de la
réactiver elle est jamais très loin
étonnante pratique pour un président qui
au fur et à mesure acté un virage
droitier pour son en même temps réforme
des retraites immigration uniforme
l'homme préfère l'axe marketing du père
protecteur que du Père Fouettard au
risque de laisser un lourd héritage à
son ou sa successeur Didier rambau
l'argent public c'est une drogue
dure pour un gouvernement pour un chef
de l'État ou même pour une société on a
on a du mal une addiction ou ça déjà un
peu non je je reviens un petit peu parce
qu'il y a eu de la bonne dette je pense
pendant la crise covid hein parce que
bon quelque part on a quand même assuré
le le le le salaire d'un je crois 13
millions de de salariés durant cette
époque il y a eu un plan de relance hein
on a découvert qu'on avait des sujets de
souveraineté on il y avit plus de
médicaments on fabriquait plus de
médicaments dans notre pays donc ça a
permis ben effectivement on va avoir une
usine de paracétable d'ailleurs dans mon
département en en diser donc je pense ça
a plutôt été de la bonne dépense un peu
une politique kénésienne comme on dit
euh on a des industries qui se créent
dans notre pays 300 plus de 300 usines
alors que ces dernières années céit il y
avait plutôt un solde négatif des
emplois industriels qui ont été qui ont
été créés donc je pense que ça a plutôt
été de la la bonne dette à mon avis par
contre maintenant effectivement c'est
sur le budget de l'État proprement dit
où il faut il faut rééquilibrer entre
les recettes et les dépenses oui quand
on dit le quoi qu'il en coûte va-t-il
revenir mais il est jamais parti en 2020
on a eu effectivement un déficit de
179 milliards et on va avoir en 2023 un
déficit de 173 milliards c'est énorme
alors qu'on avait des déficits entre
TarifAir parcoup d'énergie il sont
stoppés vont être arr mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que oui mais on voit que
c'est impossible de sortir de de revenir
au GNR pardon même temps que vous pour
pour les agriculteurs il y a son
d'autres professions qui vont faire la
même demande enfin c'est c'est pour ça
que j'emploie le terme de drogue dure
c'est c'est difficile de se
désintoxiquer de ces de ces nouvelles
habitudes ou de ces anciennes habitudes
surmultiplier on a d'autres marges sur
lesqueles on on a pas parlé des niches
fiscales par exemple aussi sur lequel il
y a il y a beaucoup de travail oui
effectivement 350 plus 350 niches
fiscales est-ce qu'on est capable y
compris pour les entreprises d'ailleurs
ou oui oui oui crédit d'impôt recherche
compris pour les
journaliste il faut le dire euh cet
argent public il a aussi servi
d'amortisseur de crise bien sûr mais
est-ce que ça nous cache pas une réalité
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais on a
si vous voulez on peut pas tout faire
avec des fonds privés d'accord et on a
besoin de réaliser des transformations
majeures notamment face à la crise face
à la crise écologique face aussi à la
crise sociale on est vraiment dans un
contexte de de polycrise face à cela
question souveraineté dont on parlait
tout à fait et donc on a besoin
effectivement d'argent public alors on a
on a besoin évidemment de bien
l'employer mais on a besoin de savoir
surtout comment le mobiliser est-ce que
aujourd'hui on peut continuer de le
mobiliser par la dette bon on sent bien
si vous voulez que les marges de
manœuvre sont limitées est-ce que on
peut mobiliser davantage de fonds
publics par des augmentations d'impôts
bon dans le dans le contexte européen on
est encore quand même assez largement
dans un dans un contexte finalement de
de concurrence fiscale on n pas du tout
d'union fiscale là aussi les marges de
manœuvre sont assez limités ce qui veut
dire que on est sans doute en fait face
à ce besoin de transformation et face à
ce besoin de fonds publics obligé de
réfléchir à des
alternatives ch inventer autre chose
effectivement je crois que on ne pourra
pas financer l'intégralité de nos
transformations par par de la dette on
peut pas rajouter de la dette à la dette
sans se sans sex risque d' faut de
l'audace oui mais alors on fait quoi
c'est on on on on émet de l'argent qu'on
remboursera pas enfin juste parce que
sinon je comprends pas bien je crois
qu'il y a il y a pas mal si vous voulez
de propositions HM à mettre en en débat
d'accord donc je vais pas être
nécessairement d'accord avec tout ce que
je vais évoquer là comme on va pas faire
on va pas faire toute la liste mais mais
celle qui vous semble vous intéressante
on peut par exemple se demander si on ne
peut pas faire face à la crise
écologique comme on a fait face à la
crise sanitaire et financière est-ce que
par exemple on peut pas euh demander aux
États donc de réaliser des emprunts pour
financer des investissements de
transition et euh demander à la banque
centrale de s'engager à racheter
d'accord aux investisseurs qui le
souhaitent euh ces ces titres d'emprunt
finançant la transition ça ce serait une
forme de quantitative easing vert
d'accord euh on a fait du quantitative
easing face aux crises financières face
à la pandémie est-ce qu'on peut pas en
faire face à la crise économique je suis
pas sûr que ce soit la meilleure des
solutions mais ça fait partie des choses
en débat par exemple il plein d'autres
soltion j'ai bien compris c'est ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a a évoqué c'était à
Davos face au patron des notamment des
grandes entreprise mondiale relancer les
les eurobonds ces empruns Européens pour
financer les investissements d'avenir on
écoute on a d'abord besoin d'avoir une
Europe de l'investissement beaucoup plus
forte pour moi c'est une priorité tout
ce que je vous dis sur le quanti sur les
cleantetech et même sur la défense c'est
beaucoup plus d'argent et donc il faut
une stratégie de l'investissement qui
doit marcher avec de moteurs il faut
plus d'investissement public européens
et donc nous devons ouvrir une phase de
nouveaux réinvestissement comme on l'a
fait dans la crise covid et peut-être en
osant à nouveau des eurobondes sur des
priorités la première ministre
estonienne a eu le courage dans un pays
qui était plutôt réputé pour être frugal
comme on dit de proposer des eurobondes
pour l'industrie de défense et l'Ukraine
allons-y sur des grandes priorités
d'avenir mais on doit investir beaucoup
plus Chrisine cardéan votre avis ça
avait marché effectivement au moment de
la crise covid la crise sanitaire
effectivement c'est peut-être une bonne
solution mais parce qu'on a l'impression
parfois que les États-Unis par exemple
sont plus habiles que le l'Europe pour
manier ce genre d'outil je crois que
vous avez fait un article un jour sur
l'hélicoptère monnaie ce qu'on appelle
l'hélicoptère monnaie c'estàd le fait de
distribuer directement de l'argent aux
gens plutôt que de le faire passer par
divers organismes d'aide mais ça ça
soutient la dépense mais ça c'est pas
fléché
si la
transation
PE ment toujours les bons ce que font en
ce moment les États-Unis avec l'IRA l'
le fait de faire venir des
investissements en échange d'IDE fa
voilà on l'a pas fait de manière aussi
massive en Europe ou effectivement les
normes européennes on en parle dans un
instant mais je voudrais vous entendre
là-dessus sur sur C cet emprunt européen
il il y a des pays Emmanuel Macron il
faisait référence d'ailleurs les les
frugos a quoi Pays-Bas Suède autrich il
m'en manque un
Danemark pas facile à convaincre il est
en Suède en ce moment ça fait partie de
de des objectifs de ce de cette c'est cl
B comme ça vient d'être dit au lendemain
de la crise sanitaire c'est ce que
l'Europe a fait he je crois qu' 750
milliards d'euros qui ont été injectés
dans des dans des plans de relance donc
on voit bien un petit peu la la
continuité que qu'Emmanuel Macron
souhaite soite impulsé mais quand il dit
ça ça veut dire qu'il est bien conscient
que il a n'a plus suffisamment de marge
de manœuvre pour réformer et engager les
réformes qu' souhait faire sans réussir
à convaincre ses partenaires européens
de relancer un grand emprunt on est dans
une Europe quand même on est on on n'est
pas tout seul je sais bien c'est pour ça
que c'est compliqué et ben donc oui donc
il faut arriver à à convaincre nos nos
partenaires européens quoi je pense que
c'est et notamment les Allemands oui
mais ça traduit bien la prise de
conscience effectivement d'une impasse
dans laquelle se se situent les les
finances publiques donc avoir un emprunt
européen mutualiser la dette européenne
ça donnerait un petit peu plus de marge
manœuvre si la banque centrale s'engager
à racheter les titres auprès des
investisseurs privés là aussi ça
augmenterait un petit peu les marges de
manœuvre cela é an tout ça reste de la
dette et tout ça reste dans un cadre de
capitalisme financier verdit qui change
pas
fondamentalement le modèle dans lequel
on on vit alors les règles européennes
on va en parler tout de suite avec
Quentin calm est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'il faut les garder est-ce qu'on peut
en sortir bonsoir Quentin bonsoir
bienvenue à vous 27 pays membres
évidemment au sein de l'UE qui doivent
respecter des règles budgétaires qui
sont strictes quand même voilà depuis
1997 effectivement le pacte de stabilité
et de croissance fixe les règles de
discipline budgétaire les pays
s'engagent à maintenir leur déficit sous
la barre des 3 % du PIB leur dett
publique inférieure ou égale à 60 % de
ce même PIB ces objectifs objectifs
visent à faire en sorte qu'aucun pays ne
laisse ses dépenses plomber ses voisins
surtout depuis que l'Union européenne
partage une même monnaie commune alors
certains pays dont la France sont loin
de ses objectif et ça relance le débat
sur l'intérêt de ce Pact voilà on en
parle depuis le début de votre débat si
on prend les 27 États membres on voit
que les pays du sud de l'Europe avec la
France ont des dettes qui dépassent les
100 % fin 2023 la dette de la France iné
ainsi 111 % du PIB on le disait dans le
sujet de de Cécile Sixou ce sont au
total 6 pays lieux qui ont dépassé cette
barre des 100 % du PIB il y a bien des
sanctions qui existent Thomas des
amendes peuvent être infligées aux
pays-membres jusqu'à 0,5 % du pb à versé
auprès de la Commission européenne la
France a été ainsi épinglée entre 2007
et 2017 mais n JIS payé d'amende alors
il faut quand même préciser que depuis
2020 la crise du covid puis la guerre en
Ukraine ces règles elles sont suspendues
exactement la Commission européenne a
décidé d'activer une clause dérogatoire
prévue par les traités pour suspendre
temporairement l'application des règles
européennes mais ce délai devait
s'arrêter au 1er janvier 2024 écoutez le
commissaire européen à l'économie en
mars de l'année
dernière nous confirmons que la clause
dérogatoire générale du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance sera
désactivée à la fin de
l'année comme vous vous en souvenez nous
l'avons activé à la mi-mars pour la
première fois dans ces premières
semaines dramatiques de la pandémie
c'était une décision sans précédent et
c'était la bonne décision voilà donc
désormais les pays-membres doivent
reprendre leurs économies mais dans le
même temps Thomas l'Europe a décidé de
réformer les règles du pacte de
stabilité cela fait un an que la réforme
a été lancée l'idée est de prévoir des
délais pour rétablir les comp publique
sur plusieurs années autre idée des
sanctions moins lourdes mais appliquées
cette fois-ci les ministres de
l'économie se sont mis d'accord sur
cette réforme des règles c'était fin
décembre mais les différenes instances
européennes entre le Parlement le
Conseil et la Commission il doivent
maintenant négocier ils espèrent aboutir
avant les élections européennes h merci
beaucoup Quentin alors dans son discours
de de politique générale ce mardi
après-midi Gabriel hatal a confirmé
vouloir revenir à un déficit de 3 %
d'ici 2027 Chris card tiens déjà d'où ça
vient pourquoi 3 % qui qui a décidé ça
est-ce qu'il y a une logique
scientifique économique ou est-ce que
c'est politique je crois que c'était
dans les années 80 à l'époque de miteron
mais c'est un certain Monsieur abeille
je sais pas si vous avez fait un article
làessus a très très longtemps un certain
Monsieur abeille qui était un
fonctionnaire au ministère des Finances
c'est lui qui a eu cette idée qui a été
reprise ensuite par le ministre un
fonctionnaire français ou non non c'est
vrai vous creuserez vous irez sur
Internet est-ce qu' sont pas obsolèes
ces règles oui je pense que on pourrait
y mettre un peu de la souou oui je crois
oui je crois qu'effectivement on se
sentirait mieux quoi en mettant un peu
plus de c'est c'est un c'est est-ce que
c'est un corset qui nous handicape pour
et je reviens cette transformation C
transformation aussi important on était
censé les revoir ces règles on était
censé les revoir en profondeur et et en
fait elles vont demeurer et
effectivement C c'est un corsé c'est un
corset
budgétaire
qui qui nous
handicape pour les dépenses de de
transformation que l'on a à réaliser
alors je pense que ça ça n'empêche pas
si vous voulez de se poser la question
de savoir justement si euh il ne faut
pas réfléchir à autre chose que la date
pour pour pouvoir financer ces dépenses
de transformation mais clairement si on
avait des règles un peu plus
qualitatives et un peu moins
quantitatives que cellees-ci ça
desserrerait un peu les taux or là on
garde les taux très serrés et on n' pas
d'alternative donc les dépenses de
transformation et bien on ne pourra pas
les faire on le voyait très bien sur la
carte bah forcément les États en rouge
ils ont envie que les RG ça soupliss oui
puis on les respecte pas de toute façon
on les respecte pas c'est règle quand on
dit 60 % pour la dette et 3 % pour le
déficit en fait ce qu'on demande c'est
un chemin pour montrer qu'on s'achemine
peu à peu vers le 3 % de déficit en
partant de 5 ou 7 d'ailleurs et de même
que la dette elle va redescendre de 111
% à 60 % c'est ce qu'espère en fait
l'Europe en en ressortant ces règles là
mais mais on les a pas respecté depuis
tellement longtemps on les respecte pas
mais ça ça organise une pression oui oui
oui ça organise une pression mais ça
donne aussi une contrainte pour
réfléchir parce que on parle par exemple
de la transition énergétique on voit
bien qu'on a un gros souci quand même
devant nous hein pour pour financer et
comme vous dites il faut trouver des
idées on voit bien crise après crise
gilets jaunes et là agriculteur que on y
arrive pas on peut pas taxer
indéfiniment ou alors il va falloir
trouver une façon peut-être de protéger
les plus modestes qu'on sait pas bien
faire on sa pas bien cibler en fait mais
le coût social de la transformation
environnementale et quels que soit les 3
% en europeah voilà on va être face à un
problème qu'on ne sait pas gérer à
l'heure actuelle il y a des rapports le
rapport pisanifhéri qui dit peut-être
qu'il faudrait faire comme ça peut-être
cibler les plus riches essayer de pr le
voir voilà ça coûte 60 milliards donc la
contrainte nous donne quand même
transformation environnmentale
invtis milliard don 34 milliards de
fonds public la contrainte de toute
façon qu'elle soit sur les 3 % ou quoi
on va la voir puisque ce mur là on l'a
devant nous sur les sur les sur
l'écologie mais autre chose moi il y a
un point quand même que que je trouve
important c'est que on avance toujours
des politiques publiques on les on les
additionne à chaque gouvernement à
chaque quinquena chaque président on n
pas beaucoup d'évaluation moi je sais
que la Cour des comptes a fait une
évaluation par exemple au moment du
covid de tous les aides il y a eu
quelques effets d' ben pas tellement
mais on fait pas ça beaucoup par exemple
sur les taxes d'apprentissage enfin sur
les primes d'apprentissage quelque fois
il y a des entreprises qui se font plus
d'argent que le le salaire de l'apprenti
on vérifie pas
souvent les dépenses il faut les choisir
mais il faut les choisir en en bonne
duforme c'est-à-dire il faut savoir là
où on dépense trop pas assez est-ce que
c'est efficace et on le fait jamais
parce qu'on rajoute des couches parce
que c'est de la communication je fais C
je fais ça il y a quelques évaluations
qui existent et donc et donc on fait
rien hein sur le crédit impôt recherche
ou sur le le cice il y a des évaluations
qui montrent que euh ce n'est pas très
créateur d'emploi et pour autant et bien
euh on maintient euh C on maintient ses
aides bon allez on va on va parler de
parce que la la question centrale du
débat on on y a répondu au tout début
c'était la question de ce mot faillite
il y a quand même je veux pas être un
oiseau de de mauvaise augure mais la
question de la note de la France la
France comment on est noté par ces
fameuses agences de notation elles sont
trois moodies standard and P et Fritch
ratings qui pèse à L3 95 % du marché
pour l'instant ell maintiennent la bonne
note de la
France alors double a c'est une bonne
note hein si on essayait de faire une
échelle de 1 à 20 ce serait un petit peu
comme si votre copie auobac avait 18
donc ça reste quand même sur une bonne
note alors on n plus triple A comme le
sont par exemple les Allemands ou les
Hollandais qui ont la meilleure note qui
ont disons un 20/ 20 mais ça reste quand
même une très bonne note et parmi les
meilleures notes au monde donc c'est
vrai qu'on aimerait un peu avoir le
triple A ce serait plus plus plus
flatteur mais on reste sur une très
bonne note alors on va expliquer
pourquoi Christine cardéan pourquoi la
note de la France reste bonne ben comme
il le disait ah oui pourquoi on a encore
ce double pourquo encore un double a
avec 3000 d'abord parce que les les
français payent bien leurs impôts donc
on sait que les recettes F fiscal rentre
bien c'était pas le cas en Grèce par
exemple au moment de la crise de la
dette parce que en Grèce les armateurs
payent pas leurs impôts et et c'est eux
les les plus riches et les autres les
imitent à partir de là donc la France
paye bien ses impôts la France est aussi
un pays riche c'est-à-dire que si on
prenait tout ce qui est sur les compte
d'assurance vie des Français et cetera
on s'aperçoit qu'on pourrait sans doute
rembourser je crois la
part que qu' l'on doit à l'étranger la
part de notre dette qui est détenue par
les par les étrangers par exemple il y a
une part importante de notre dette 47 %
de la dette quand même détenu par des
étrangers c'est ça c'est un record en
Europe parce qu'en général en Italie
c'est plutôt 25 % et même aux États-Unis
c'est plutôt de l'ordre un/art de la
dette pres la moent cet argent ça
rassure les les les marchés de se dire
la
francegent il sont là voilà il des RCH
sont là puis troisème point pourquoi les
agences de notation nous font encore
confiance parce que il y a ce chemin
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et que
notamment Bruno l est là pour dire oui
on va réussir à limiter à diminuer le
déficit et et à retomber la dette en
dessous de de 100 % la réforme des
retraites elle a été faite aussi pour
rassurer les marchés et notamment les
agences Deah oui c'est évident ouiou
voilà on a pas beaucoup entendu hein à
l'époque c'était c'était un mot interdit
hein dans la communication
gouverementale oui Mo personnellement je
regrette parce que ça aurait permis de
mieux comprendre le pourquoi de de de
cette réforme et puis pour compléter ce
que Madame vient de dire effectivement
on a encore la confiance des marchés
financiers on est un pays où on a un T
de chômage quand même qui a fortement
baissé on est un pays qui
réindustrialise quand même he par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu il y a il y a
une dizaine d'annéesin je le disais plus
de 300 usines on investit dans les
secteurs d'avenir la batterie électrique
pas raésente et et d'autres sujets bon
donc voilà pourquoi effectivement on a
les agences de notation font encore nous
donneent encore de bonnes notes
gésabelle coupé souéran qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si la note baissait
ah si vous voulez c'est un ça nous
coûterait encore plus cher de rembourser
la dette c'est cette spirale là qui
s'enclencherait l'information que
produisent les agences de notation est
utilisée par les par les investisseurs
s'il y a une bonne note ils sont un peu
moins exigeants en terme de de coût de
l'emprunt donc de taux d'intérêt à payer
par les état que si la note est si la
note est mauvaise si la note est
mauvaise bien ça signifie en fait un un
risque de un risque de non remboursement
plus grand et les les investisseurs et
bien face à ce risque sont plus
exigeants ce que tout ça traduit
également c'est finalement la pression à
laquelle les États se soumettent
lorsqu'ils empruntent sur les marchés
financiers voyez que quand ils financent
leurs dépenses en empruntant sur les
marché financier et bien ils sont
obligés de se soumettre aux exigences du
marché c'est ça aussi qui doit nous
amener finalement à penser à des
alternatives est-ce que on peut réaliser
toutes les transformations que l'on a
besoin de réaliser en se soumettant à la
pression des marchés les marchés sont
changeants c'est dire que les
investisseurs aujourd'hui restent tout à
fait friiant de titre de dette publique
mais demain et bien ils peuvent très
bien se montrer plus défiant bon un
scénario à la grecque pour la France
c'est à l'instant inimaginable bah sans
doute pas pour la France mais il faut
réfléchir si vous voulez à la zone euro
dans son à la zone euro dans son
ensemble il faut pas oublier que entre
2010 et 2000
on a été confronté à une crise des
dettes souveraines qui aurait pu
emporter
complètement la la zone euro dans son
ensemble c'estàdire qui aurait pu faire
s'effondrer la construction européenne
on se soumet à ça en fait alors on a
commencé à évoquer des pistes des des
des solutions on voit la une pendant sa
campagne présidentielle Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il proposait d'annuler tout
bonnement la dette covid Christine
cardéan est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est uneidé fol après tout pourquoi pas
non mais si elle était détenue par les
Français on pourrait dire on l'annule
donc hop vos assurances VI vous les
reverrez jamais et cetera mais ce sont
des étrangers qui comme je le disais qui
pour la moitié on souscrit à nos
emprunts donc si on le rembourse pas et
bien ils ne vont pas nous reprêter de
l'argent à nouveau donc on va pas
pouvoir comme on n'est pas à l'équilibre
on a toujours besoin d'argent pour pour
faire tourner le l'état donc pour bien
comprendre on enclencherait un un cercle
vicieux une une spirale catastrophique
alors il s'agit pas de il s'agit pas de
la annulé euh pour les investisseurs
privés c'était pas ça la proposition
d'annulation de la dette d'abord c'était
une proposition d'annulation
conditionnelle de la dette c'est-à-dire
à condition que les sommes annulées
soient réinvesties dans la transition
écologique et il s'agissait d'annuler la
dette en fait au bilan de la Banque
centrale européenne ou plus largement
d'ailleurs au bilan consolidé de la
Banque centrale européenne et des
banques centrales nationales parce que
parce que la dette CIDE en fait elle est
elle est au bilan de la Banque centrale
européenne aujourd'hui pris pour gérer
pour gérer la crise sanitaire la banque
centrale a racheté énormément de titres
de dett publique donc elle s'est
retrouvé
créancière des états elle détient 30 %
de des dettes des dettes publiques des
pay Z toalement absurde de d'ffacer
cette cette dette publique de l'ardoise
de la Banque centrale européenp alors un
ça dépend du moment et de il est clair
si vous voulez que on peut pas faire ça
tous les 4 matins d'accord c'est
vraiment c'est une c'est une c'est une
solution c'est une solution exceptionnel
mais effectivement annuler annuler des
créances au bilan de la banque centrale
à l'actif de la Banque centrale
qu'est-ce que ça fait bah ça fait une
perte pour la banque centrale est-ce
qu'une perte pour la banque centrale
c'est grave bah non c'est pas grave et
heureusement que ça ne l''est pas
d'ailleurs parce que aujourd'hui les
banques centrales dont la Banque
centrale européenne réalisent des pertes
d'accord si ces pertes étaient graves on
aurait de quoi s'inquiéter donc en fait
si vous voulez tout dépend de la raison
pour laquelle ces pertes son sont
réalisé aujourd'hui la Banque centrale
européenne réalise des pertes parce que
elle est obligée de rémunérer les
réserves des banques bien il vaudrait
mieux qu'elle fasse des pertes pour nous
aider à financer la transition
écologique ce serait quand même une
bonne chose mais c'est pas une solution
c'est pas une solution pér je voulais
juste dire suis pas sûr que simple je
suis pas sûr que ce soit si
simple je pense qu'il y aura
effondrement de l'euro je pense que tous
les pays qui font défaut sur leur dettes
regardez l'Argentine ils entrent dans
une spirale il y aura effondrement de
l'euro si on narrive pas à réaliser la
transformation écologique et soci vou
intervenir làdessus un mauvais message
très au niveau de l'opinion à mon avis
le message est dévastateur parce que ça
veut dire qu' nous faisons plus d'effort
finalement de maîtrise de nos dépenses
continu ben oui il faut faire un effort
d'investissement surtout c'est cet
effort là en fait qu'on vous demande de
réaliser oui oui et le budget de l'État
on laisse on continue quoi trou
comcer auprès de chaque citoyen ce que
ça le message qui est passé quoi c'est
ve dire on a tous on est tous endettés
on rembourse un prêt de pour un
appartement l'impression que ça donnech
sort sa baguette magique pas du tout je
pense qu'il faut il faut beaucoup de
pédagogie si vous voulez sur le pouvoir
monétaire des banques centrales ce
pouvoir monétaire des banques centrales
on a su le mobiliser face à la crise
financière face à la crise sanitaire et
bien mobilisons-le face à la crise
écologique l'annulation conditionnelle
des dettes publiques au bilan des
banques centrales ça fait partie des
solutions c'est sans doute pas la
meilleure parce que c'est une solution
ponctuelle en revanche le pouvoir
monétaire de la Banque centrale le fait
que la banque centrale aujourd'hui et
bien sont en capacité de subventionner
les banques c'està-dire de créer de la
monnaie sans contrepartie financière
pourquoi est-ce que on ne développe pas
ça précisément pour subventionner tout
ce qu'on a besoin de subventionner dans
les transformations à réaliser on a
compris vous étiez pas d'accord les uns
et les autres mais Christine cardand
peut-être je reste et on va conclure
là-dessus sur sur sur cet enjeu majeur
de transformation de notre euh de de nos
économies euh et et des solutions à euh
à inventer elles sont elles sont pas si
simples euh il y a euh par exemple
Fabien Roussel qui proposait de taxer
les les les super riches on peut dire
c'est communistes sauf que à Davos il y
a 260 milliardaires et millionnaires qui
euh disent mais taxez-nous des
milliardaires américains en général oui
vous avez écr un livre sur les sur les
milliardaires plus forts que les États
eux ils veulent surtout pas donner leur
argent aux États parce qu'ils
considèrent que les États l'utilisent
mal c'est quoi leur le oui ce dont je
parle en fait c'est euh c'est c'est Bill
Gates dans le domaine de la santé c'est
zuckeberg sur les réseaux sociaux enfin
c'est c'est les les six grands
milliardaires américain et c'est pas
forcément cela si Bill Gates a donné sa
fortune pour pour la Fondation
effectivement est en train de donner peu
à peu sa fortune mais ceux qui qui
demandent à taxè c'est je dire a 260 oui
c'est ceux qui c'est des milliardaires
éclairés j'allais dire en France vous
aurit du mal à trouver des milliardaires
qui qui disent on est prêt à à à payer
davantage il considèrent qu'en France
ils sont surtaxés alors qu'aux
États-Unis ils sont beaucoup moins taxés
donc en échange entre guillemets il
redonneent un peu en philanthropie ce
qu' ce qu'ils ont économisé en impôt
merci beaucoup et donc à découvrir dans
le livre qu'on a vu s'afficher derrière
vous et jésabelle coupé souberéran je
rappelle le titre du vôtre le pouvoir de
la monnaie on est aux éditions les liens
qui libèrent merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à
demain 18h 22h sur Public Sénat et puis
je CIT Fabien Roussel mais justement et
le secrétaire national du Parti
communiste sera demain matin l'invité
politique d'orian Mancini il sera 8h
dans la matinale de Public Sénat belle
so à toutes et à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi sur un thème qui peut
paraître aride la dette c'était
passionnant merci
[Musique]
beaucoup